I'm living out of my car thank you thank
you Amazon it's broken me it's it's I
mean mentally and physically it's it's
broken me
I'm not the only one this is this is an
epidemic literally I didn't ask to be
injured at Amazon this was their fault
this was their faulty equipment
[Music]
[Applause]
they think that the injury was mild and
that I should have been healed already
the only thing I want compensation for
is the injury that I sustained and
Amazon we don't recognize these
allegations as an accurate portrayal of
working at Amazon we're proud of our
safety record
[Music]
give me one month's worth of pay for to
shut me up
[Music]
the station that I entered myself on the
previous year in October they were still
broke eight months later they still had
not been fixed
[Music]
for a warehouse job where people
literally fall out and from from
the heat
I think that it we should be paid more
than $15 an hour to me they don't care
about their employees I feel that
there's no sympathy there's no empathy
they literally I feel like they do not
care it's all about pushing the worker
to the absolute limit
Amazon recently announced it was hiking
its minimum wage up to $15 an hour a
move that was welcomed by employees we
are also establishing a new Amazon
minimum wage of $15 an hour
[Applause]
however some Amazon staff have been less
enthusiastic about the pay rise saying
that other benefits have been cut to
make it possible some workers claim
they'll actually be thousands of dollars
a year less well-off and others complain
the new staff will get as much as some
of the longtime employees now Amazon's
new minimum wage will affect some
250,000 employees as well as more than a
hundred thousand seasonal workers
concerns have been raised about the
elimination of its stock awards program
and the retailer has also phased out
incentive payments an amazon says that
the increase in the hourly wage will
compensate the losses from previous
benefits Shannan Alan who we heard from
a bit earlier I gave us her views on the
new pay scheme there's a condition that
comes with the $15 an hour which is they
took away our stock and they took away
our bonuses that we receive every month
I think that by them taken away the
stock and the bonuses was not a good
trade-off we all signed contract I
signed it in Amazon signed it they have
to come up with a new contract for us to
sign that's exactly what this states
right here in this states that they gave
us two shares of stock and that we
receive stock every year that we are
there so I have
six shares that I will never be able to
cash in because they've taken it away
from me and because I've been on medical
leave it will it won't vest for her till
you